you know Chris in the aftermath of the
memo last week from the Commissioner
telling everyone the draft is proceeding
as scheduled and thou shalt not complain
about it or you will be disciplined
nobody's complaining because any time
you spend complaining is time that you
could be spending getting ready for the
draft and I think for all the teams the
message is go this thing's coming up in
24 days and you better be coming up with
ways to make the most out of the time
you have yeah that's right it does it's
all systems go and I think most guys in
the NFL have been approaching it that
way you know whether they like it or not
you know that's a different story now
I'll say this Mike you know I think a
lot of guys in the NFL are enjoying this
you know yesterday a little out of the
road routine do they wish they had more
access to certain things certainly but I
will say you know Mike the few friends
Scouts I'm texting with you know just to
say hi what's going on drak talking
draft they're really enjoying their time
home this is a group of people who grind
and when I say they grind I mean it's
unlike any other grind that's out there
as far as time in the office watching
film time away from family traveling
around the country a lot of these Scouts
GM's you know head coaches coordinators
they'd be on the road or grinding in the
office big time right now so the fact
that they're at least at home with the
family around I think they're very
appreciative that and the most part but
yes times are weird and people are
having doing adjust and it seems like
the NFL is a no excuse community anyways
and I know that guys like John Lynch and
other GM's are just going to continue to
the trudge forward and there is one very
specific area where plenty of work can
be done to know more about the prospects
in this year's draft I I got
clarification yesterday from the league
every team has the ability to contact an
unlimited number of prospects three
times per week per prospect each guy can
be contacted three times per week by
telephone or video conference and they
can keep them on the line for up to an
hour each time so Chris you can get up
to three hours per week from every
prospect if you want to do it so you you
spread that out over the course of the
last you know five or six weeks leading
up to the draft you've got a lot of time
you can spend interacting with these
guys and yes it's no replacement for
sitting across from them at a table
especially got some tough questions
asked about some off-field issues or
whatever the case may be and none of
this replaces the ability to find out
physically and medically where guys are
but there is an opportunity here to
spend a ton of time talking to and
interacting with these guys
in order to find out more information
about them and and to at least have some
context for getting to know them a
little bit better you know as we all
know and you know you know specifically
in the NFL hey yeah the workouts are
there we know they're very important the
you know getting to know a guy being in
a room with them very important you know
what's what's his football IQ all that's
important you're gonna be able to get
some of this yeah you're not gonna get
that personal I to eye contact but to be
able to get on FaceTime or Skype or
something like that whatever it may be
and have some conversations to the guy
that you're really thinking about
investing a lot of money into you know
dedicating a spot on your roster to say
damn we need this position and you're
the guy you know these are things that
are in necessity you know these are
big-time investments these organizations
are making and you got to get to know
these guys to a degree so you know it's
a good idea by the NFL to open it up
this way can keep keep continuing these
conversations week by week I think
that's a great way to instead of just
one visit where you get to see a guy one
or two days you start to get a feel for
the guy on a weekly basis hey I'll call
you you know Wednesday at 7:00 every
week for the next three weeks you start
to get to know a guy his parents his
family whatever it may be the
surroundings and how comfortable and how
well you might feel he may fit on your
football team and I also think Chris if
you've got a guy where there are
concerns about how reliable he is you
tell him we're gonna call you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday at 11:00 a
tarp and if he's not there right if he
doesn't answer or if he's all groggy or
if he has waked and baked as someone who
can't you can't because you have the
show but
or maybe you can't but but that's a way
through that rhythm and that routine to
see whether or not this is somebody you
can rely upon to show up for work I
think that's very fair - yes you know
you're gonna you get a good feel as this
guy got his life together he's got his
act together a thing scheduled out is he
acting mature and grown up and
professional that way you know these are
all things there the players are gonna
have to you know take into their own
hands it is it's weird times but I do
think you're right that's another
inkling that these coaches and GM's will
be able to get looking into these
players seeing how well organized they
got this whole thing during this weird
weird process but nonetheless I'm glad
the NFL changed the rules here they had
to of course I mean how can you make the
number 15 pick in the draft
if you have no feel for what the human
being you're going to draft is like so
at least we're doing something they're
positive and we'll see where it goes
from there another thing to keep in mind
- and I addressed this over the weekend
in a mailbag column that I did it's
important this year more important than
ever to have a good agent who is looking
out for you because the agents who are
connected will be advocating for their
clients aggressively with coaches GM
Scouts over the course of the next three
and a half weeks and we'll be protecting
those clients against the negative stuff
that other agents will be saying about
them we've speculated in the past maybe
one of the reasons why Lamar Jackson
lasted until pic32
two years ago is he didn't have an agent
to protect him against other agents
representing other quarterbacks
propagating the Bill Polian nonsense
that this guy should be a receiver
there's no agent to push back against
that and advance the narrative that
Lamar Jackson is gonna be the MVP of the
league in 2019 and you better not miss
the boat so with no workouts no medical
no anything other than these
opportunities to have phone calls and
video conferences the agents are going
to be the ones you know the trusted
agents the ones who have the network's
the ones who are very good at persuading
people they have more power than usual
because that may be the closest thing
that you're gonna have to get inside of
who a guy is because you're not gonna
get to see him you're not gonna get to
see him work out you're not gonna get
the poker houses
hey if it's an agent that you trust and
he says we've had this guy looked at the
knees fine that goes a long way and I
think it makes it more important to have
a good agent who's respected and
connected in this draft preparation time
Chris what a hundred 100 percent agree
with that you're right I mean the agents
the middleman and to have a middleman
that a team or organization trusts to
say hey listen you know my guy know you
talked to him on skype or facetime
two or three times but you got to trust
me this is what I'm seeing too those
relationships are they're gonna go a
long way the other thing I'm noticing -
Mike I mean I just feel like because
there's no school workouts or personal
workouts we're not hearing as many
rumors about guys because you know not
as many NFL people are congregating at
one spot and talking to each other and
that's how the rumors get out you know
that's what happens though you're you
know at the University of Texas pro-day
and oh hey did you hear Johnny did this
blah blah blah blah and then it spreads
around the league that hey Johnny's got
an issue with this we heard it last week
at the workout whatever it may be but
that's one thing I don't think you're
gonna hear a lot throughout this process
this year because we don't have scouts
and coaches you know congregating in one
place nearly as much or at all and the
players taking the visits hey so-and-so
has visited the Steelers and the Bengals
and the Browns and this team in that
team there's no visits and who knows if
they're calling him because every team
can call every player three times per
week and you know that that dilutes the
significance of getting a phone call if
you get a visit when they only have 30
of them to give out that's a big deal if
you get a phone call who cares they can
call everybody if they want to so that
flow of information has disappeared and
it'll be interesting to see how the
agents try to to sprinkle that
information out there as to oh hey my
guy is in demand he spent three full
hours this week on the phone with
coaches from this team this team this
team so it's just a different reality
and I think I think that because we've
never had to do it before you got a lot
of people they're still trying to figure
out how best to work this to their
advantage and I I think that over the
course of the next three weeks we'll
start to hear some of that about who's
talking to whom the most but for now
it's just cricket
and I have a feeling that for a little
while longer at a minimum were it's
still gonna be not really hearing much
and there's plenty of teams that like it
that way Chris well yeah it's not you
know the one thing I thought about too
when I heard some of these rules I just
thought man you know this could make
life even harder for coaches and GM's -
I mean nothing it's hard enough as is
but now you think about what players
write and let's say you got you know
player X he's got 20 teams that are you
know interested in taking them somewhere
in the top three rounds whatever it may
be you know how does he organize all
those calls they're gonna go into the
night time I think at some point I mean
this guy's got a workout he's got a
regimen he's trying to you know keep
track of on a daily basis right now I
just look at that to to go man some of
these coaches right you gotta watch film
or GM's watching film all day and then
probably have to get on the phone with a
bunch of players at 6 7 8 o'clock at
night and start talking to them and
building relationships and getting to
know these guys too so you know even
though most of the NFL or all of it is
working at home you know I can promise
you these guys are working hard they're
grinding and they got lots to do yeah I
agree with you completely in one last
point before we take our break and these
were comments that came over the weekend
from Steelers GM Kevin Kolbert to the
Pittsburgh tribune-review and I think
it's something important to keep in mind
now Art Rooney jr. bill Nunn and dick
Hale and they put together the best
draft in NFL history in 1974 and they
didn't have pro days they didn't have
combines they were allowed on what they
felt those guys were as football players
if we have to go into this draft with
that same mentality that's our challenge
and we'll do the best we can 5 Hall of
Famers in 1974 Chris four of them
drafted one of them not drafted Donnie
shell but no pro days no combines and
this is gonna be a reminder that what
you see on film is what you should trust
and sometimes all that other stuff just
gets in the way alright we're gonna take
a quick break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports